[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la moitié de la france a vécu 80 minutes
alors de colombe n'a payé 18 mille
francs certaines places de tribunes pour
voir quinze rugbymen français en maillot
blanc opposé au rouleau compresseur
sud-africain apparaît souvent au diable
et même parfois à l'abominable homme des
neiges pas impressionné du tout par la
réputation d afrique en date les
maillots blancs donnent des frissons de
joie aux 50000 spectateurs de colomb dès
le début du match le jeu à la diable des
français sème la panique chez les
rugbymen du diable sur un contre kroos
manque d'un rien laissé on avait
pourtant pour lui les yeux de chimène
dans les tribus maintenant c'est la
panique de l'autre côté les avants
sud-africains par tarrafal de locomotive
lancée à 100 à l'heure il faut percuter
sec pour les arrêter et d'un et de deux
et d'autres pas encore un autre
pas le temps de respirer et du panache
avec ce tarif fixe
on est tenté de trouver un peu trop
téméraires lorsqu'il contre attaque
comme en ce moment de plus dans lignes
de bus quatre femmes de corps et
bouquets numéro 12 mai tous ses
adversaires dans le vent on y croit à la
victoire seulement voilà elle tient à
petit
regardez ce qu'il faut pour manqué un
essai tout fait le petit rancoule est
tout seul un ford
pourquoi faut-il qu'un ballon de rugby
niçois parents ça n'arriverait pas des
choses pareilles dans les mêlées
ouvertes on ne se fait pas de cadeau de
toute manière le porteur du ballon de le
garde jamais longtemps
[Applaudissements]
sa chose qu'on est passé
vous avez raison monsieur l'essai n'est
pas marc une tonne et demie de muscles
en pleine action voilà ce que ça donne
sur un terrain de rugby
mais le rugby est un jeu varié un jeu
magnifique belle attaque française
joliment contré par les springboks ce
qu'ils repartent à leur tour
on n'a même pas le temps de reprendre
son souffle dans les tribunes sur le
terrain non plus mais où est donc passé
le ballon neuf voilà il est pour les
français
la victoire est au bout de cette attaque
si vous êtes cardiaque ne regardait pas
on se demande encore comment cette balle
de match a pu être manqué c'était la
dernière attaque de la partie la france
n'a pas gagné mais tout le monde est
d'accord les rugbymen français sont les
meilleurs du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nouvelle de l'assassinât de patrice
lumumba a fait naître un peu partout
dans le monde des manifestations de
protestation manifestations inspirées
protestation dirigé sans contredit tous
ces cortèges ceux de londres comme ceux
de moscou avait un but identique
l'ambassade de belgique à moscou
cependant monsieur h s'était également
rendue responsable du ca du leader
congolais
mais après le caire c'est belgrade qui a
sans doute vie l'assaut le plus violents
menés contre l'ambassade de belgique
la police a dû faire appel aux lances
des pompiers pour tenir en respect les
manifestants
singulier destin que celui de monsieur
lumumba au côté duquel on voit ici
monsieur guy zinc à son continuateur six
mois avait fait de l'homme fort de
léopoldville ce prisonnier convient
traité sans ménagement un jour de
décembre dernier son exécution vient de
rallumer le brûlot congolais
[Musique]
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
monsieur h a été tour à tour vilipendé
par monsieur auryn ceux tenus par
monsieur stevenson débats orageux que
devait d'ailleurs interrompre une
manifestation de noirs américains a
sorti deux bagarres et de hurlements
on n'avait jamais vu cela aux nations
unies
le tango n'a pas fini de peser sur la
vie internationale
[Musique]
le 12 février les soviétiques ont lancé
un nouveau satellite
rien de nouveau jusqu'ici mais de ce
satellite est parti en direction de
vénus une fusée qui se rapprochera de
l'étoile du berger après un voyage de
quelque 100 millions de kilomètres
allons-nous connaître le secret de vénus
qui s'entoure d'une atmosphère nuageuse
assez semblable à celle de la terre
apprendra-t-on que la vie est en train
d'y suivre l'évolution suivie par notre
planète que dans ces brumes les premiers
végétaux y sont nés ces végétaux dont on
retrouve les traces fossilisées vestiges
des forêt de fougères arborescentes qui
couvrait notre globe voici un milliard
d'années venus en est elle à ses terres
où la première vie animale se
manifestait dans des marécages et où
dans la merci lurienne apparaissait ces
étranges nautile dont l'espèce n'est pas
morte
résistant à tous les bouleversements à
travers 600 millions d'années alors que
disparaissait d'autres espèces dont les
musées concerne les fossiles
[Musique]
est elle parvenue à ce temps où les
premiers vertébrés les poissons ont fait
leur apparition
poisson cuirassé d'abord puis poisson à
mâchoires dante et lointains ancêtres
des requins ou plus avancé encore au
temps où la vie passée de l'eau sur
terre avec les premiers sauriens souches
des grands reptiles secondaire à moins
qu'au milieu de tornades gigantesque
beaucoup plus en arrière 15 100 millions
d'années peut-être la vie n'en soit
encore qu'à ses premiers balbutiements
et que ne commence à jaillir du monde
minéral la toute première traces
d'organismes vivants avec les premiers
virus
[Musique]
le soleil se lève t-il sur une vénus
déjà vivante ou sur une planète sans
autre écorce qu'une mère de méthane
veine usic qu'il nous dira t-il tout
cela chez fernand aubry le visagiste
voici le carnaval
un carnaval qui s'apparenterait au songe
d'une nuit d'été
si shakespeare n'était pas si loin mais
est il vraiment si loin aujourd'hui les
légendes de la forêt viennent jusqu'à
nous dans ces masques éblouissant qui
raconte en dentelle en perles en
branchages en fourrure un plus mais en
paillettes la vie secrète des faits et
des dryades d'un monde que nous
n'atteignons plus qu'en songe
[Musique]
qui ne seraient sensibles à ces
silhouettes en train d'une magie rentrer
dans le secret des choses et qui ne peut
remettre au milieu de nous faut-il le
dire que par l'intermédiaire d'un mas
en dix ans orly est devenu le premier
aéroport d'europe continentale avec la
déviation spéciale de l'autoroute
il n'est plus qu'à huit minutes des
portes de paris
[Musique]
jeter au dessus de la nationale 7 sa
piste de 3 km 300 accueille depuis 1959
les plus lus aux appareils à réaction
là où voici 35 ans n'existait que de
hangar à dirigeables des installations
s'étendent maintenant sur plus de 14
cents hectares et en gardant la est le
plus grand du monde et des ateliers sont
alignés sur un kilomètre et demi
[Musique]
indépendant des compagnies aériennes
l'aéroport de paris entreprises
nationales qui construit et exploite les
aéroports parisiens achève la nouvelle
aérogare dorny cet immense édifice de
six étages à une ossature métallique qui
pèse plus que la tour eiffel
ses façades où s'harmonisent l'acier
inoxydable l'aluminium et la glace est
maillé ouvre presque 2 hectares au
rez-de-chaussée à hall de 190 mètres de
long où se succèdent les clichés des 27
compagnies clientes de l'aéroport attend
les voyageurs dans un cadre ultra
moderne pilier revêtus de serpentine et
d'aluminium plafond en lan d'aluminium
[Musique]
l'automaticité est partout porter au
maximum et les portes vitrées du hall
s'ouvrent et se ferment tout seul tout a
été prévu pour accélérer la circulation
des voyageurs aux ascenseurs 20 escales
à tort la possibilité d'un trafic
pouvant atteindre 15 cents passagers à
l'heure au premier étage la galerie
marchande qui conduit aux airs de départ
présente une façade en glace de 170
mètres de long elle apparaîtra aux
voyageurs de 1961 à l'aérogare d'orly
une plaque tournante géante du trafic
aérien l'aéroport de paris a fait appel
aux matériaux les plus modernes acier
inoxydable aluminium et glace
il est dès à présent possible d'assurer
ici la réception de 6 millions de
passagers par an une réalisation à
l'échelle de l'aviation commerciale à
réaction
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]